ضعنا في اخر
التطورات نعم خمس ساعات على استمر بدء
واستمرار هذه العمليه العسكريه ولا يزال
الاحتلال مشتبك داخل هذا المخيم يحاصر
المخيم من كافه المحاور هنا نرصد في هذه
الصوره لربما تشاهدون تواجد او تقدم اليات
الاحتلال
العسكريه ومحاصر المنزل لحتى هذه الساعه
وسط ال
اشتعال النيران داخل المنزل المحاصر الذي
يظهر في هذه الصوره قوات الاحتلال اطلقت
ما يزيد عن 10 صواريخ من طراز النيريا نحو
هذا المنزل وايضا اطلقت عدد من الصواريخ
الحارقه داخل المنزل منذ الساعه الثانيه
قوات خاصه اسرائيليه ووحدات خاصه تسللت
الى ال الى مخيم نور شمس في مدينه طول كرم
حاصرت منزل يعود لاحد المقاومين وفتحت
النار صوب من تواجد في المنطقه الامر الذي
ادى لاصابه
اربعه اربعه اشخاص تم نقلهم الى المستشفى
فيما اندلعت اشتباكات مسلحه في انحاء
متفرقه من المخيم مخيم نور شمس الذي انسحب
الاحتلال منه في ساعات الصباح بعد عمليه
عسكريه مشابهه استمرت ست ساعات منذ ليله
امس وحتى ساعات الصباح الاولى اعاد
الاحتلال اقتحام المخيم بوحدات خاصه
اسرائيليه تسللت الى وسط المخيم حيث لا
تزال الاشتباكات متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه
هنا نرصد ايضا في محيط المنزل تواجد
لاليات الاحتلال العسكريه التي لا تزال
مت مخيم
فانه يؤكدون ان هناك ك على الاقل مقاوم
واحد داخل هذا المنزل يشتبك مع الاحتلال
بالرغم من اشتعال النيران به و الانفجارات
التي وقعت داخل هذا المنزل فيما لا يزال
الاحتلال يحاصر المخيم من شتى المحاور هنا
ايضا
نرصد على الجهه الاخرى في منطقه جبل النصر
وامتداد المخيم تواجد لاليات الاحتلال
العسكريه و عشرات الاليات التي وصلت
بالفعل الى المخيم برفقه عدد من الجرافات
سواء من طراز دي 9 او جرافات الدواليب
التي عملت على هدم اجزاء من المنزل
المحاصر وسط الاشتباكات المسلحه قوات
الاحتلال منعت طواقم الاسعاف من الوصول
الى المخيم فيما اطلقت النار صوب كل من
يتحرك في هذه المنطقه بشكل مباشر هنا نرصد
مركبات الاسعاف التي منعتها طواقم او
منعها الاحتلال من التقدم نحو المخيم حيث
تتواجد في محيط دوار سيف ابو لبدا
بالتزامن مع استمرار تواجد عشرات الاليات
العسكريه التي تحاصر المخيم من كافه
المحاور تمنع تحرك
الفلسطينيين سواء بالدخول الى المخيم او
الخروج منه قوات الاحتلال وهذا الاقتحام
يعد حقيقه الاعنف على مخيم نور الشمس منذ
الانتفاضه الثانيه عام 2002 حيث منذ ساعات
الظهيره اشتباكات لم تتوقف في كافه ارجاء
المخيم ولم يقتصر حقيقه على المخيم
الاشتباكات امتدت نحو المدينه مدينه طول
كرم اثناء تقدم الاليات العسكريه وايضا في
محيط مخيم طول كرم لكن الصوره في داخل
مخيم نور شمس هي الاصعب حقيقه منذ اعوام
عده ومنذ عقود حيث الا ان الاحتلال يطلق
النار بشكل مباشر صوب اي جسم متحرك صوب
المنازل بشكل مباشر اطلاق لعشرات
الصواريخ صوب المنزل المحاصر وقوات
الاحتلال بالفعل يعني لا تزال حتى هذه
اللحظه تحاصر المنزل